Hãy ăn năm tâm mời theo dзupi Nam,
tồng thông mấy đồ nân trăm lên đường công dù,
Malaysia, Nhật Bản Văn Quốc,
chuyến thâm đồ tiền tới chua,
kể từ khi ông trở lại nhà chẳng.
Phải Malaysia, ông thâm dự hình y cấp cao Asia,
lần thứ 1 bị bầy.
Pương đời hợp cao vực và dự kiến kiế tổn thường
mại sống phương.
Hoa xinh tình kiếp bảo chuyến li sẽ tải hình liền căm kết với đông nằm mà.
Nơi các nước chung khu vực kiếp vào,
Mỹ sẽ đưa ra thông diệm sấu sàng,
bây kâm kết với chục cung hướng và thương mại.
Nhất là khi các bạn pháp thử quan vẫn gây chính khái,
phân nhìn bản phản Quốc,
tâm thuộc trăm sẽ thảo luận về ăn ninh,
thế quan và định hướng hợp táu chung của cô A.
Đánh giống sự cùng của quán hị đồng mình
cho bối cạnh cho kêu tăng cường năng lực phòng vệ.
Đồng thời cũng định ngọt khá năng nối lại đối thoại với chụi tiền.
Đáng chú ý,
của gặp dự kiến với chụi chung của tập cập định được coi là có hội,
để hai bên tình tình nói chung,
với việc nhật bộ thử nhập khầu.
Nếu bắt kinh nổi lại 1 năm 3 và hạn chế dòng chánh hư liệu cho phía tâm niên,
chánh huy cơ các thử thuộc mại lâu khác,
bứng thử một chăm phần chăm trình đi có hiểu lực.
Truy công dư là này cho thấy nghĩ đang chủ đậu định hình cuộc diện cho anh,
hãy định dương,
bằng lối thoại thuộc mại và cân bằng chế lực.